what's up reject nation moving on to
loki
changes up my beanie just to mix it up a
tad bit let's watch this already damn it
exclusive clip they said
end game
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah i hope that's the opening of
the show
you just start there
cool
where did you travel to
yeah reminds me like when iron man was
in the sand
wow you're taking me somewhere to kill
me
no i'm taking some place to talk oh
i forgot he was in this do you like to
lie which you just
did because we both know you love to
talk
how long have you been here i don't know
it's hard to say you know time
is differently here in the tba nice
you'll catch up
i love the imagery
[Applause]
that lady loki
hurt yours
oh dude i love this music
this looks so awesome damn
oh he's definitely becoming like a time
agent for them
it's gonna be the doctor who with the
mcu wow
short hair loki
i'm down he said heimdall right
he said
coolest way to hop into the bifrost
dude
what did you expect
okay so far that takes the cake for me
that was
the most effortlessly enjoyable i'm not
gonna lie that definitely took the cake
for me uh
between like falcon winter soldier one
division trailer don't get me wrong
those were
amazing and they really are this just
slightly edges it out i love
the like sci-fi fantasy mystery tone i
hear one of the people involved with
rick and morty is behind this as well
and you do get that vibe yeah like it's
not it's like
wacky out there but especially with like
that owen wilson scene
you know how rick and morty has like the
citadel and all that and people
and the tva like the time variance
authority
they are kind of like that group which
i'm forgetting the name of it rick and
morty
but you know what i mean loki is just
the rickest rick
but you know how in rick and morty there
is that that one group that
deals that enforces the law when it
comes to time meddling and that's kind
of what the tva
is here and it looks like they're
recruiting loki to be a part of the tv
are like okay you know what you're an
outlaw and maybe they're blaming him for
like the events that happened in endgame
and how the timeline got all messed up
here
that's kind of the impression i'm
getting so if you want to get out of our
debts
if you want to you know have this strip
from your record you got to become a
time agent for us and that's sort of the
impression i'm getting here but it looks
like
along the way like okay fine i'll agree
to it but then he starts having his own
fun
then he starts doing his own thing how
did you get kind of a weird rick vibe
from him
because he's always in control and he's
irreverent and yeah like his plans
probably won't go right according to
plan but part of his charm is watching
him improvise in the moment and rise to
whatever stakes are thrown his way it
doesn't
necessarily seem like a specifically
anthology show but again with the
shifting tone of all
of letters and stuff it looks like we
have a such a broad spectrum of things
we can possibly do with the show so just
yeah like as a viewer this got me giddy
for possibility and i
absolutely adored that payoff to the
scene from endgame yeah like using that
as the introduction here and i do yeah
like if they use that as the intro to
the show i would be very excited just
the same
i mean we've known a few people who've
been following the news we've known that
this series will focus on that version
of loki
but especially for newer audiences to
not be confused like
what i thought loki died at the
beginning of infinity war but if they
watch this china goes
oh that makes a lot more sense now
you know yeah totally i mean that
closing shot sequence was so cool we
seem to go with bifrost hopping before
but that's easily the coolest way to do
it that's tom cruise style
yeah yeah and they said heimdall and i
but this is
the loki from his timeline because i was
like what heimdall still alive
yeah i thought he died but this is the
loki from his uh that's what got me uh
confused but is it drisable going to
show up in this series as well
i mean i'm loving the trajectory of what
we're seeing here because not only does
it look
fun but there's there's also this real
dark
undertone throughout and i love that
we've gotten three trailers for
i mean there's more trailers out but
we've got in the three
big main most advertised ones and yet
they all feel so different from one
another
and this is just another addition to
that there's something that feels more
mysterious in a different way than what
wanda vision
is you know it's more like what the
hell's loki gonna get up to and how is
he gonna take advantage of this he's a
prisoner at first
but then he you know he's gonna find
ways to use this to his advantage
yeah he's gonna find ways to bend the
rules too yeah to exactly to his
advantage
this really does strike me as a
potential for a doctor who
esque show within this universe yes
because loki with the power that he
already has
now being sort of co-opted it almost
reminded me of like a suicide squad
scenario in that way where it's like
well
you're too formidable to have running
around we're going to need to use your
right right
and some leverage so like i love
bringing that flavor in and as an excuse
to keep this character alive who has
died in iterations of the timeline this
seems like the most fun way to do that
and yeah like i love some of the shots
especially in the middle
where you get these ominous looking like
shots of silhouettes and people with
lanterns like it looks like maybe some
of the secret edge too will be some
really cool atmosphere some really
amazing design work because i loved all
the
just production values from this you
know this is uh this is awesome
guys what'd you think of this loki
trailer between the three which is the
one that takes the cake for you the most
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell
are you excited for owen wilson to be in
this last but not least
andrew hayes i'm excited to be shouting
out our long
time not only patronage but friend
andrew hayes
because i found out recently he's
actually part of a band
and he he slaps the he's slapping the
bench
it's called pandas and the needle fish
ooh that's a great name
it's a great name i suggested it give me
credit yeah
and and royalties and residuals for when
you hit it big then let us open for you
as like stand-up comedy
nah i can't hear that but also he's
going to film school
yeah you're just living every creative
dream you're doing it
all you're taking advantage of now that
you're 45 years old you're finally
pursuing your dreams i'm so happy for
you dude i hope that when you're in film
school
you get to be an awesome director cast
some actresses
get cancelled blacklisted in hollywood
never able to work again because you
wanted them to be in your music videos
for panda
and the needlefish i mean you know it's
a pretty big opportunity
especially because you get to meet the
guys in the band it'll work on me all
right send me that casting call
i'll be there i'll be there to hang off
your leg in adoration
i'm just gonna stare at you for the rest
of this all right again